[Applause]
[Music]
the tallest man ever to walk the earth
was 2.72 metres tall and he quickly
became an international sensation so can
you imagine what life would be like if
you grew to almost double that height if
you kept growing until you were 5 meters
tall
you'd be half as tall as a telephone
pole 3 times as tall as a refrigerator
and 2 and a half times the size of
Shaquille O'Neal
how would you navigate a world built for
smaller people would everyone treat you
like a freak or could you use your size
to skyrocket to power this is what if
and here's what would happen if you were
5 meters tall
when most people think about being
really tall they imagine a world full of
the usual perks associated with height
but the reality is these benefits stop
at a certain point standing at 5 meters
tall
you'd be a walking world record and
people would treat you accordingly
human bodies aren't built to be this big
not only would your size make simple
physical activities difficult but it
would also slow down your neurological
processes so how long could you
realistically survive
aside from growing up too close to a
nuclear power plant the most likely
reason you'd ever reach anywhere near
five meters tall is if you had something
called extreme gigantism extreme
gigantism is a rare phenomenon that has
a few possible causes the most common is
pituitary gigantism which is caused by
an over secretion of growth hormones
from cells in the pituitary gland or the
presence of a tumor on this gland the
tallest human in recorded history is the
Illinois born Robert Wadlow who stood at
2.72 metres
he died at just 22 years of age due to
complications from an infected blister
caused by a faulty leg brace Roberts
case is just one example of how
difficult life can be for extremely tall
people living at these incredible
Heights brings all sorts of health
consequences
with it some of them are good but most
of them are bad let's start with the
good
if you grew to be 5 meters tall you
could eat almost as much food as you
want without suffering the typical
weight gain consequences as your height
reached giant levels your metabolic rate
would increase drastically meaning you
would need far more food for sustenance
being extremely tall would also decrease
the risk of heart disease and diabetes
and the benefits pretty much stop there
as your body shot up in size and gained
mass your bones would have a difficult
time keeping up in order to support your
new weight even with mechanical
assistance to help you walk around you'd
need to be extremely cautious where you
walked as soft surfaces like soil could
collapse beneath your weight and the
fun's just getting started other things
that would come along with your newfound
height would be an increased risk of
blood clots and cancer of deeper force
and a much lower burger pulse root that
means your nerve signals would be sent
to the brain at a much slower speed
resulting in more delayed reactions and
difficulty with conversations activities
and processing visual information add to
that the fact that most of the world
isn't built to accommodate you and this
whole thing starts to look like more of
a curse than a blessing if humans were
to evolve to be 5 meters tall we
probably have to start walking on all
fours to handle the weight and that
would introduce a whole new set of
problems but that's a topic for another
what-if
[Music]